big congratulations to you both so fans
are finally getting what they wanted
which is of course the season returning
how are you feeling every season that it
comes out i am uh pleasantly surprised
and overwhelmed with the response from
fans
uh people just
they get they're they're so invested in
this world
that we've all created and you know
that's just it's it's really fulfilling
to be able to
um
you know do a job that you've worked so
hard for
you know your most of your life since i
since i've been doing this since i was
15 and
um
it's incredibly gratifying to be able to
be a part of something that people enjoy
so much i think our fan base has from
the get-go been one of extreme
feeling uh around the show and i think
that's no accident the show
is all about feeling right i mean season
one was there was so much grief there
was a lot of
uh trauma
and
but of course this burgeoning romance
and this promise of of love and and
passion and
you know it's not just mel and jack
you've got you know everybody's getting
it on in virgin river it's fantastic i
mean it's just like
it's it's like a soap opera in many ways
you know
and i think audiences love that and and
the writers have done a great job of
piecing out little bits of information
and then leaving them hanging and
wanting more i think we're shocked by
its success to the extent that people
are liking it but people just seem to
they just love it and um that
it feels wonderful to be putting
something out there that people like
i'm pregnant
and i don't know who the father is
we can resolve the issue using a
non-invasive paternity test
i can't do that right now
why not
because if we find out that mark's the
father it could change how i feel about
our baby
we've had so much baby drama going on
who's the daddy you know um so we kind
of get some baby questions sort of
revealed and answered this season so
jack is the father of mel's baby but
jack is not the father of the twins i
mean how much information are you
getting before you guys you know deliver
each episode did you know where this
journey was going to take you
yeah
yeah we heard some we heard some there
were so okay at the i'm going to tell
you what happened okay i'm gonna be so
at the beginning of the season
charmaine's babies were still jacks
this was the outline charmaine's babies
would would always be jacks and mel's
baby was gonna be marx
and then about like really close to the
end it completely changed and the
writers came back and they were like
so charmaine's babies are not jacks
and mel's baby is jax and i'm like all
yes thank you
i said i said i just you know when we
talked about the beginning of the season
before we started season four
i just i really i was like oh it's just
heart it feels heartbreaking to me
if mel is pregnant with mark's baby it
just feels yeah
like a letdown
so i'm really glad that they decided to
go in the other direction martin what
did you make of this decision this this
twist in the plot
i was similarly
relieved i felt that at this juncture
like season four
we're we're
year you know many seasons in we've
watched these guys with their mutual
troubled past come together and then
there's this promise of love right and
their connection and their attraction is
undeniable so the potential can only be
for good
but like all good dramas we then have to
watch them
navigate through all of the conflicts
and
where they're incompatible and trying to
figure that out and which keeps you
compelled
but i think it's a perfect time to give
the audience something to really
celebrate you know obviously there's
people are going to want the wedding and
i don't know if that's going to happen
but
there's certain things that you want to
give the audience i tell you it's like
virgin river when you see the opening
shots and all the location shots you're
just put into this dreamy land and
you've got these dreamy relationships
jack and mel i mean oh my gosh we just
can't get enough of them
alex what gives i mean is it a pre-wreck
for you every job you have to have like
a really steamy hot leading man from
justin to martin i'm saying
yeah i couldn't you're you're
broke up what was that oh whatever i
don't think exactly what i said martin
i wanted to record it man but it is i
mean
yeah i'm ruined now i you know i've had
um yeah the last two jobs that have
really overlapped each other um for me
in the last couple years
martin and justin so lovely to work with
both of them i'm not going to tell you
who's a better kisser because
that would be rude
um
it's clearly not me because then you'd
tell me
no no i'm sick it could be rude to
justin i don't know
well luckily you you've got a husband
that's that's a bit of a dreamboat too
so it's not like you're going home
anything lesser exactly there's a lot of
very attractive men in my life i mean
congratulations oh for you
so how are things setting up for season
five here you guys are already back to
production
um so how are you i know you can't give
me specifics per se but how are you
hoping things
unfold specifically for these two
alex
um
well what i'm looking forward to this
season
um
i think mel
mel's
uh journey
through like
from her childhood
becomes
more in focus
um here and there throughout the season
so that we can understand sort of where
she's come from
and how that informs um
how she behaves now and uh
but you know i think that there's
going to be some
similar uh twists and turns along the
way i've um
i know what happens up until episode six
and
um
yeah i was just i was just given the
outlines
uh they're not even scripts yet the
outlines up until episode six and um are
you happy
i'm very happy i think it's
okay i don't know i don't know if fans
are going to be happy we'll have to wait
okay fair enough martin are you pleased
with how things are panning out for
season five with the outlines and the
scripts that you've received so far
i am you know i think what's interesting
about this point in the show
there's a lot of uh closure
with charmaine
right it's like that's been put to bed
so to speak like okay
and there's a release from that you know
and i feel like and now
mel and jack have an opportunity to just
focus on them and
their baby and their life you know and
there's so much hope in that and i think
there's a lot of just possibility and i
think for jack it's about sort of
starting over starting new
and he's getting help he's really
he's really committed to
you know healing his stuff and i think
he feels that he wants to
put all that stuff behind him so he can
show up for this woman and for this
family and
so there's a lot of hope and i think the
audience hope you will feel the buoyancy
of that but of course being a
tv show there's going to be some uh
there's gonna be some obstacles
[Music]